les amis j'ai rencontré des jeunes de
tous les milieux
plusieurs qui était passé à travers des
moments difficiles il était cynique face
aux politiciens n'étaient pas convaincus
mais ils m'ont dit tous nous ressemble
tu parles comme nous tous nous voit
aujourd'hui québec je veux dire merci
évidemment évidement évidement les
résultats ne sont pas ceux que nous
voulions mais l'accueil que j'ai reçu au
québec m'a fait chaud au coeur
ce premier rendez vous ce premier rendez
vous électoral nous a permis de mieux
nous connaître
j'ai eu la chance de vous démontrer que
nous partageons les mêmes valeurs
je suis reconnaissant pour le soutien
que nous avons reçu ce soir mais ce
n'est pas été assez on va continuer à se
battre pour vous
[Applaudissements]
merci mais c'est nous n'allons pas
laisser tomber le québec nous
continuerons à y être présents je
continuerai d'être présent au québec
j'ai dit j'ai dit que nous allions unir
les progressistes du québec et du reste
du canada et ensemble nous pouvons le
faire et nous allons le faire
jack a commencé le travail
nous devons de continuer parce que les
progressistes c'est nous merci mais amy
et est très bientôt
on ne lâche pas